Ah, ah, ah, ah.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
I do believe this is on.
Can we please lower the music?
Please.
Thank you.
Ah, ah, ah.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone, for being here today.
Yes.
Greetings, my fine constituents.
I'd like to say, first of all, thank you for your continued support of the Made Mint Mint Phantom YouTube channel.
You may be wondering what today's debut has been scheduled to be all about.
Oh, well, I will tell you, you know, I began my journey back in July of 2020.
Mm-hmm.
And it has been a long year.
Wait, five.
Well, I've been back for...
Oh, hold on.
My notes.
Hold on.
I wrote that wrong.
It has been...
It has been a long, nearly five years of haunting.
Yeah.
Yeah, 2020 is a long year, huh?
And I'm sorry, serious.
Well, I would still like to keep haunting your everyday lives and, you know, continue stealing all your life force.
That sweet, sweet life force.
I also felt it was time for me to branch out into a new avenue.
And so I would like to extend my talents into something I feel is very passionate to me.
And that's idols, baby.
I put out an international wide search for the most passionate, the cutest, the most talented, the best of the best, the cream of the crop idols that the world has ever seen.
And I combed through thousands of entries.
And I definitely didn't use a lottery random number picker.
And so the true best of the best stands here with me today.
And I would like to announce that I have created my own new VTuber idol group and their debut will be in just a few minutes.
I would like to introduce you to Twinkle Dogs.
Yes, Twinkle Dogs.
These five new sparkling members of Twinkle Dogs will make you feel joy, happiness, and many other human emotions that mean fun.
Everyone has that dog in them, that spark that makes those dogs twinkle and shine on their idol journey.
And that's how Twinkle Dogs was born.
I would also like to announce that at the end of their individual debuts, there will be an original song created by yours truly.
The title, Make You Coon Coon Cooter Doon Friday Night.
So please stick around until the very end.
Okay, okay.
Yes.
So their concept is something that hasn't been quite done yet in the idol VTuber world.
I would even say the idol world.
We are quite the revolutionary minds here.
AKA me, mind.
You may have heard of AKB48's concept, the idols you can meet.
But I have changed the concept.
I've made it better.
Instead, our members are the idols at your own convenience.
And I know VTuber fans want to talk to their favorite VTuber at any time.
And with this new system, you can.
The system works like this.
Each Twinkle Dog will tell you their personal phone number and you can call them.
Isn't that just so exciting?
Now.
Are you all ready to meet the members?
We have a brief introduction video.
That was cut.
Due to budget constraints.
Anyway.
Give your best group howl for Twinkle Dogs.
Describe it to us.
Oh, okay.
Brief introduction video.
Look, it goes like this.
First member.
Well, I can't.
I can't do their voices.
You're just gonna have to hear the lore, see the lore, experience the lore.
Them themselves.
Oh my god.
I was so nervous.
Wow.
This is my debut.
I can't believe I'm here.
Okay.
I don't have very much time.
So I'm being told that I have to, you know.
Pick up the pace.
All right.
I'm gonna throw you.
Wait, I already messed up.
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna show.
Not throw.
I'm gonna show you guys.
Myself.
In three, two, one.
Hi guys.
My name is Sen.
My lore is that I'm a nerd and I'm also a goon.
Okay, I'm gonna show you guys my introduction video.
Not video.
Sorry.
I don't have that much money.
Why do I keep saying video?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Anyway, I'm very cool and I'm very awesome and you'll see from my.
Powerpoint.
Yeah, welcome to Sen's nerd den.
I'm number one, two, zero, four.
Yeah, ignore the other text on the screen.
About me.
I wrote a lot in my audition.
So I'm just gonna read it word for word because it's kind of a.
Impressive.
So I am indeed a freaky wisp.
I'm 23.
My color is blue in the group.
I am INFP.
I don't actually know what that means.
Okay, but and my height is average.
I'm a I'm the one who keeps the freak meter down low.
When you first meet me, I could be stoic and a bit standoffish.
But once you get to know me, I open up into being witty.
Performative and yes, freaky as I have absorbed much influence from freak phantom herself.
Give it up for my boss.
I've been a TLDR.
I am overwhelmingly have a personality of an artist with all the good and bad that comes with that.
My name is Sen.
Did I say that?
Oh, I have a one-liner because I'm a goon, right?
And I'm a nerd.
My one-liner is actually, I'm the one that stole your heart.
Yeah, pretty good, huh?
Yeah, and this is what I look like.
Did you guys see the whole model?
See it?
Yeah.
Yeah, pretty good.
Pretty good.
Pretty cool.
Yeah.
And um, did YouTube crash?
Why is my chat so awkward?
On my debut?
This is so messed up.
Hold on.
Am I live?
Anyway, I'm just going to keep, oh, there we go.
I'm live.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, I'm so nervous.
Oh my gosh, guys.
Anyway, yeah, my phone number is down here.
And oh, my secret talent.
I'm always pitch perfect.
You might hear me in like the end of like the song that we're in.
That we did.
It's like...
That's my secret talent.
My likes and my dislikes.
Yeah, I like video games.
I'm such a nerd.
I like animals.
Such a nerd.
I like anime and manga.
Dinosaurs.
Creative pursuits.
NASCAR.
That's like my most normie hobby.
My boss.
Yeah, I like her.
And nerding out.
I'm really ready to nerd out at any time.
Yeah.
My dislikes.
Any weather that isn't perfect temperature.
Gosh, I'm just really, you know, picky like that.
It's got to be like, can't be too hot.
Can't be too cold.
And smelling bad.
So you can't call me stinky.
And crickets.
Why did I write about that?
Crickets.
Oh, here's my dislike.
I have a lizard and my beef with the crickets that start chirping randomly in our cage in the middle of the night is intensive.
Oh, yeah.
That's so horrible.
Yeah.
And deer.
Because one jumped out in the middle of the road and did a front flip in front of the first car.
I totally totaled it.
And since then, anytime I see a deer, I give him a big old middle finger.
Yeah.
Oh, I forgot to say.
Oh my gosh.
You're probably wondering why this guy is on my thing.
People say I look like him.
What do you guys think?
I'm putting on my best smile right now for you, though.
Yeah.
You see it?
Anyway.
I also don't like when people talk to me, but I don't want to talk.
So, uh, don't talk to me.
Unless we're talking now.
That's fine.
Oh, sorry.
I'm being told to wrap it up.
My schedule for this week.
I took one out of your book, Miss Phantom.
Love you.
Yeah.
Monday dredge, Tuesday dredge, Wednesday dredge, Thursday dredge, Friday dredge, Saturday dredge, Sunday dredge.
See you there.
Thanks, guys.
Hope you enjoyed my debut.
Thanks.
Bye.
Oh God, I still had the reverb on.
It's my turn now.
And, uh, yep.
I'm gonna throw a show myself.
Wait, I'm gonna show myself in three, two, one.
The name's Patty.
P-A-D-D-Y.
Not like Patty.
Like, you know, not like Patty.
Like, like a girl.
Yep.
And I'm your DILF of the group.
And let me show you what I'm all about.
Yeah, I don't know where I am.
Okay, old man Patty's here.
Yep.
Young nerds beware.
Uh, oh, my lore is I am, uh, I am the ghost of future nerds.
So, Sen, you better look out.
Uh, you're probably wondering how old this, uh, old timer is.
I'm 30.
And I already died of old age.
My color is white.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm old, but like, I'm a cool, old, uberly, tall, and hot.
Sorry, I have a cough.
And sorry, I don't have a phone to give you, but I have an old Tamagotchi.
And that's also my manager.
So if you need to talk to me, uh, you can contact my manager in my Tamagotchi.
I'm just gonna put myself here.
And, uh, my likes and my dislikes.
I don't like anything.
And, uh, uh, my hair is supposed to be red, can you tell?
Or is it too faded?
Yeah.
What's based?
My, my, I do have foundation.
My dislikes are squid.
And, uh, organizing things.
Oh, wow, uh, thanks for super chat.
Uh, I'm just gonna give that to my boss.
Oh, don't worry about that.
I hate loud machines.
I didn't write any reasoning why.
I just don't like these things.
And I also hate, uh, onward march of time.
My schedule.
Monday, I, is now, I think.
And I'm going to a debut, which I am doing.
And then I will nap.
And then tomorrow I have off.
Because of my mesotheliomia.
Wednesday, I'm warning the youth of their future downfall.
So, everybody under the age of 30 can join.
And, or over 30, you can also, uh, speak wisdom to the youngins under 30.
Friday is organize my pills.
It's a headscan.
Sorry, sorry, I have a cough.
And then Saturday.
I don't know.
We'll see if I'm still around by then.
Sorry, I forgot.
Sunday, I also have that day off.
Because that's grandpa's day.
Oh, thank you guys for the superchats.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, you like my BGM?
It's custom.
Pretty good.
Anyway, um, I'm being told to wrap it up now as well.
So, thanks for coming to my debut.
And y'all, you guys are all very pretty.
And, oh, daddy!
That's exactly what I wanted to be called.
And you're probably wondering why my hand does that.
It's because I'm just perpetually stuck in the I'm-actually pose.
Because I'm the ghost of future nerd.
Don't be like me.
Children.
Okay.
Don't forget to stick around for the original song at the end of today's stream.
Thank you.
Bye.
Oops.
I'm Sheba.
I tell you about Sheba.
My name's Sheba.
Time to tell you about Sheba.
My name is Sheba.
And I'm so rich.
But I'm missing a few body parts.
I, it's no big deal.
Wisps with cute butts.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ah, yeah.
And, I just, yeah, uh, Sheba, Sheba, uh, really likes spreading...
Dislikes.
Bright lights are no no.
Did I mention I'm six f...
Get that away from me.
Uh...
I'm also...
Six fat...
I forgot my schedule.
Anyway, Sheba says thanks for coming to my debut.
Enjoy the rest of the debuts.
Bye!
Oops.
Hey guys.
Um...
My name's, uh...
My name's Indy.
And, um...
It's kind of funny.
I applied to, uh, you know...
I was an Indy Vtuber and I applied to be part of a company and, uh...
I actually don't really know how I got here.
I've been told I need to...
introduce myself.
I'm not... My name is Indy.
Not like... It's not a pun.
But it's kind of funny.
I don't know why I'm here.
I don't know how I got here.
Uh, okay, uh...
Oh.
Sorry, I'm an Indy Vtuber.
I guess I'll just put myself above it.
I have to fill it out as I go, because I...
So, um...
Indy.
That's my name.
I'm 30.
Once you get to know me, this is kind of a bad place to meet.
Uh...
Uh, I'm sarcastic.
Um...
I'm, uh...
I like to banter, you know?
Uh...
Um...
They're telling me to say a town.
And my phone number?
Whoa, guys, this is not me typing my phone number.
This is... I think someone took over my computer.
This is not me typing.
This is... This is not me typing.
That's my number!
I
don't really know what to do here.
My likes and my dislikes?
Okay, uh...
Uh, I like golfing.
I like gammering.
I like working out.
I like reading and manga.
I like drinking coffee.
I don't know, normal guy stuff?
This is totally normal, no?
And my dislikes?
Oh gosh, they're really pressuring me.
I like, or I don't like scary stuff.
I'm a weenie.
Sad.
I hate, I dislike hot...
ass summer.
But I like...
hot ass.
Okay, that's important to differentiate.
Uh, and it's almost summer now.
Oh man.
And I hate cold ass winter.
And tomatoes.
This is so normal.
I don't think I belong here.
I don't think I belong here, you guys.
I don't think I was supposed to...
I don't think this was my schedule.
Oh my god.
Monday.
Oh my god!
This is not me typing, you guys.
This is not me typing.
Oh my god.
This is, something is on my computer.
How did it, how did they get my information?
Guys, please.
I don't know, I don't know how else to reach you.
I don't know, hold on.
I'm just gonna get rid of the Powerpoint.
I don't know how else to reach you.
But you guys, I need your help.
I need, I'm not supposed to be here.
This is, this was a mistake.
I don't think I'm supposed to...
Hello.
I am a duck.
My name is Duck Q.
My catchphrase is...
Quack it, don't whack it.
Let me show you about me.
I am 33 years old.
My birthday is today.
Happy birthday to Duck.
I am Mallard.
Please call me on the phone.
My likes.
Friends, math, science, drawing, languages, animals, and invidia.
My dislikes.
Drama, not theater, kind, politics.
Do you agree with Duck?
I think, if you like and dislike these things, Duck can be good friends.
Schedule.
Duck Pond Retaste Test Roblox Bread Carrying Tour My Pond Quack Challenge.
How many breads can I eat?
Very excited schedule.
Please take care of Duck.
Thank
you for watching.
Their original song.
What was it?
They worked very hard on it and so did I.
Thank you very much everybody.
Enjoy the music video.
It's a Friday night.
I'm just a dog, but I belong in a zoo.
Your heart's so loud, I can hear it from the other room.
It's a good-a-do, Saturday, whoops, Friday night.
Give me a chance to make it sound right.
I've got the day wrong, I should've checked it twice.
I'm a dog, I can be naughty or nice.
I can see a twinkle in your eyes.
A little lick on your nose for a surprise.
Don't turn me down or I'll be so glum.
You can pat my head or scratch my bum.
It's a good-a-do, Friday, whoops, suddenly it's Sunday.
Where do the days go, I can't even try anymore.
You know what they say.
Dogs can't breathe.
It's a killing computer, next weekday.
No matter when, it is a bug in your way.
Sorry that I misread the calendar.
Maybe we can try next week.
Thank you!
Everybody, please, I look forward to your continued support of Twinkle Dogs!
Thank you very much!
Enjoy the rest of your evenings!
And yes, please, you saw all their schedules.
Please follow Twinkle Dogs and enjoy them for the rest of their existence.
Thank you!